you've mentioned that the term moxie
yeah is synonymous with being bold
fearless and a little outrageous what if
someone doesn't naturally have that oh I
think courage is like a muscle and you
got to just kind of exercise it I mean
that's the thing about failing and
experimentation just little experiments
and failures and some won't work in so
well and then you feel a little bit more
bold to do something bigger and then you
do a little bigger and bigger every I
mean after my big failure was always
brains future I never finished the way I
built myself back up as a filmmaker
who's had made a whole bunch of shorts
and they got longer and longer and
longer and longer then I made a feature
when I was finally ready when I was late
30s so that's how you build up boldness
is he exercised it I'm even speaking
like you know I used to be nervous
before I got up and some big event like
that commencement speech at UC Berkeley
in front of 11,000 people I my mouth was
dry I was my heart was pounding and the
first couple you know sentences you
probably can hear to my voice and then I
comfortable but even with lecturing now
I really normally don't get nervous
unless it's like you know a really big
audience you know over 7,000 or
something but now most audiences I I
just feel comfortable feel comfort of
what I'm saying how I'm saying it and
you know I I mean I think this is
another thing just as you get older you
just you know who you are more and you I
think you just if you're a more evolved
version of yourself which i think is
what happens when you get older
hopefully is you're just becoming closer
to who you are and you're more authentic
just by nature of knowing who you are
more and then other people
you just see no you're younger you're
trying to your 20s you're trying to
figure out who you are where you want to
live you're gonna be with there's all
these big questions and you know once
you start figuring those things out and
you feel more comfortable your place in
the world who you are you know it's just
it it shows i think in your work and
everything what is the moxie institute
the mosque institute is our film studio
we just gave it kind of a fun name that
was a little obtuse you know it's not
really it was in the way you know we do
we make books we make films we make
events so it is an institute in that
sense we're really interested in ideas
but we're really interested in films
plus new technologies to make social
change and we explore with a lot of new
technologies with our phone so we're
just as interested in the creation of
the film is the way we get it out into
the world
you